free for all while many americans wait
for their
coveted vaccine patiently white house is
ready to give away
shots to illegal migrants
listen well certainly the more people
who are vaccinated
uh whether they're undocumented or not
the safer we are as a country and that's
certainly the president's
point of view and it's not just the
border as homeless residents in seattle
are being put
in fema funded hotels and being given
coveted shots as well
while you wait our next guest just
returned from seattle on monday where he
saw the city's problems first hand
favorites reaction fox news analyst
lawrence jones lawrence good morning to
you
hey happy good friday thank you you as
well uh
so lawrence it makes perfect sense if
the white house is gonna let
uh migrants come on in because there's
an open door why not give them a shot
before americans
yeah it's kind of disgusting when you
look at it look we want to be charitable
we want to be a given nation
we want to help those that are less
fortunate but when you have people in
your own country
that have not gotten a shot when there's
such a surge when
there's so many lines to get the shot i
think it's a slap in the face of those
american citizens
that have been patiently waiting for the
vaccine
uh you know i i think we got to get to
the root causes of this yesterday when i
was
co-hosting the five i think i i said
that we have to
have two weeks to slow the surge there
there's a problem at the border
a problem of biden's own making because
he had incentives there
and that's only going to cause us to
have to continue to pass out this free
stuff
because as you know even if you let
these people in
they can't work unless they steal
somebody's social security number
well and uh earlier i was telling folks
that new york state
lawmakers are going to inc in a two
billion dollar fund
give unemployment insurance to illegal
aliens so
you know you just come on into the
country and new york state will pay you
up to 28 000 which
it's like okay and they wonder why their
debt is out of control right here in new
york and why the taxes continue
to raise and steve i think the thing
that that americans
feel is you're doing this in the middle
of a pandemic i mean businesses are
shutting down in new york and now you're
handing out goodies to legal i mean it's
just absurd to me right but also
lawrence that's another reason why if
you're
you know you're in a place and you're
looking to look i live in this terrible
country
i'm you know there's grinding poverty
i'm gonna go to the united states
i will get a shot and i'm gonna get 28
000
from new york state plus whatever else i
can get you know it would not surprise
me
lawrence if there has been a given the
fact that we now know that the
detention centers are super spreader
events
uh it wouldn't surprise me if there was
a plan
in the white house or the administration
to once they let the migrants in
before they say okay go wherever you
want to go call your aunt
or whoever's phone number you've got is
we're going to give you the j and j
shot before you go just so you don't
have to worry about it
but once again aside from this is
speculation
but they would once again jump the line
ahead of so many americans who have been
waiting patiently
legally here in the country well i think
the bite administration is going to have
to get their messaging right
uh moderate joe is going to have to pick
what side is he on
look again the the one as charitable as
america
americans are when you start putting
other people before them then they get a
little
upset about that and rightfully so again
like i said the beginning of the segment
there are americans still waiting for
the shot apparently there is a line
and there's different groups that can go
when you start putting other groups
before
then that becomes a problem it's the
same problem in san francisco with
education
people are not opposed to the migrants
getting in person
education because they didn't do
anything wrong it was the parents that
sent them on this treacherous journey
but the fact that their kids can't get
in person learning is why people are
furious
and of course we want as many people in
the country to get the shot as possible
it's just a question of priorities
lawrence thank you very much for joining
us live
thanks brother